[Music]
the level that i am
is like an other sports formula one nba
the best players always follow the best
players they want to be
in the top of the the game because they
are the ones they are there you know you
cannot rest or sleep because the other
one can pass you
of course we fight with everyone
with the neymar with the messi with
lewandowski with iguain you know with
the top of the best players in the world
so
i mean this is not
fighting but it's it's it's hard it's
healthy you know comparations is healthy
and we fight you know to be the best
this is why
it's my my main point it's my motivation
it's to be better than them
than them year after year to be in my
shoes is not easy
but i'm not i'm not complaining i just i
just want to say that
i'm feel happy
all this happened
because there isn't the reason is
i'm unbelievable inside the pitch this
is why the people have
so much interesting on me are you the
best footballer in the world right now i
think so yes in my mind i'm always the
best
i don't care what the people thinking
what they say in my mind
not just this year but always i'm always
the best
i'm always going to say that because i
think we have
to thinking we are the best in our area
so in my area i think i'm the best
[Music]
you have to work
i try to do it almost every day this is
why i'm in the top level many many years
i think it's not
it's not by coincidence it's a
because i do it extra outside the pitch
when i'm 12 years old most of the people
told me christian you are very very good
talent player but you are very skinny
very slim and i put it in my mind the
body we can improve
you can improve you've got gym
dedication and not work
you can improve so i've prove myself and
i think it's going well on me this is
why i'm in good shape almost all the
year and i want to carry on like that
because it's helped me a lot
[Music]
it's part of me
i'm not doing that kind of work
because i have to it's because it's part
of me
[Music]
i'm always competitive player and not
just any games i'm in the train i'm like
that in your home with my sisters with
my mom with my nephews i'm always
trying to competitive hard and try to
win
i'm like that you know i'm not i'm not i
never change
and because i like i like this i like
what i do i like my life it's part of me
[Music]
my subconscious i'm always speak with
the ball i'm always say
do it the right tragedy go to the net
of course i know
if you have
positive thoughts
this is help that things going better
and this is why i always do it i don't
think about that but my subconscious
they thinking this is why
i think the the
things happen in my life is not my
coincidence i'm always have that
that positive mind
the most important thing i knew it and
everyone know that
and he said cristiano
we have money
we have everything we have fame
and they say i have
millions and billions but the most
important thing it's the family keep
your family healthy good
and take care of your family because
this is the most important thing in the
world
a part of that of course you have your
life your private life you have your
girlfriend you have
[Music]
your cars your houses your fame
but in the beginning your family it's
always with you for the good moments and
for the bad moments
i'm always say it was the
toughest time in my life it was when i
left my family with 11 years old to live
in a different world which is lisbon
in the same country but it looks like
it's a
different part of the world i was crying
almost every day to miss my family but
i'm not i'm not regret
because it was
probably the more inten more intense
moments in my life that i that i live
through
so
without sacrifice we cannot win nothing
so i did a
unbelievable sacrifice my family too
and i think it was
i did a good option
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here